[Music]
start here start talking yeah we're
talking we're talking alright do it get
you some water by the way that's for you
buddy
hot breath hot breath water you're
really in a branding holy [ __ ] is this
called hot breath
it's called fountas water they're like a
spring water is podcast yeah it is
called hot breath yeah holy [ __ ] this is
like the most this is like not of a
comic to be this aware of Brandon this
is like you know there's like the other
side of it right here yeah I was trying
to hit it from both sides you gotta be
what else do you have besides water
I've shirts and my boy you're wearing
the shirt holy [ __ ] jacket she got me
this jacket you're like Larry the Cable
Guy you wearing on [ __ ] man this is
crazy I don't know if that's a
compliment or not it's probably not hot
now there's no time now to take it off
cuz I'm like oh jeez I'm like later the
Cable Guy and now I'm wearing plaid
Jesus this is like later the Cable Guy
that's crazy have your own in water
yeah how do you do this how do you put a
thing on here is they all they did it
they that's one of their products they
sell is like branded water you can get
so when did you wanna collab what do you
do you what do you make this you like
put it through a purifier or something
it's the most boring podcast so far of
all time I'm asking about how you make
water
it's from the Blue Spring Mountains in
North Georgia so it's like it's from a
spring it tastes good at spring water
that'll be a good font is come with
anything not shipping water like is any
of the water I get nuts but is this
shiny [ __ ] right Dasani any purified
water is tap water
oh great up and you'll even see on like
Dasani they have salt in it and they
added minerals so this is good water
know that now that I really take it out
I don't know how New York's water is you
know this is like a real small victory
set when I'm savoring the [ __ ] water
after that's set Jesus I'm glad I left
my show early to come see the end of
that oh god why could he get I was
getting cranky on stage I was just
excited to get here I wanted to catch at
least the end of it I've seen you a
couple times and
a Wednesday at the punch line you know
in the side room of a diner right I
didn't know how it was gonna go so I
want to see you in that environment yeah
it's weird man
it's the diner connected the club does
not make for like a popping crowd I
don't think I don't think it's uh it's
it's weird I at one point I said I feel
like I'm gonna walk off set and
someone's gonna put a piano wire around
my neck like in the [ __ ] Sopranos or
something but yeah was I mean the diner
is nice
yeah we're sitting in the actual diner
now doing this but you go from South by
Southwest - it was a wild few days I did
a in South by Southwest I did like a big
theater last night like a benefit show
and it was like a 2,700 seater and the
lineup was crazy was like Nick Offerman
was hosting yeah and then Gaffigan
closed it I went on before Gaffigan and
there was a the girl from my crazy
ex-girlfriend Rachel bloom which I've
never seen but she was funny she was
good I mean it was like it was a cool
show front of 2700 people he's a Traeger
yeah it was fun and then now back to
reality I mean that's how it goes right
I mean I've done you know I've opened
for some big people who are like you get
to do those you get a taste and you're
like if once you believe that see your
life you're kind of losing right you got
a you got a kind of just accept I've
talked to those people that like love
you ever flown first class how do you go
back like what you just at you don't
think I deserve this all the time okay
how long you been doing comedy I would
say close to 13 years this is 13 years
yeah yeah I knew you'd open up for a
tell yeah who else have you been able to
work Amy
lovely a lot of a [ __ ] Jim Jefferies
like so good I mean these are like
comics who've done like theater show
arenas they've opened with like big
games yeah you know and those are like
yeah you just you get a taste of what
that fan that fandom is like do those
people that go crazy for them and and a
great crowds because they're excited as
opposed to this crowd who was just drunk
and like what am i performing for these
[ __ ] reptiles in the front
or those palm beach druid us they were
like Florida drunks but you're around
the good audiences but you're also
around like amazing comedians what have
you learned from working with that level
of talent you learn a lot from mattel
because he's such a he's such a he can't
like he must just never stop thinking of
jokes he's always in joke form which
like can't be the best existence ever
but it makes for a damn good comment
made by such a pure comedian yeah you
learn you learn a little from everyone
like I've learned a lot from Amy I've
learned a lot from you know she produced
my special so she helped me put it
together and edit and so yeah you learn
had a had a really you learn different
skills from different people you know
she she was performing and you know
Elena's when I was opening for so I
learned how to really kind of hole punch
lines a little longer and how to hide
watched how she kind of conducted
herself when it's Saudia I mean as we
were saying like you perform in a big
venue one night I'm and I was opening
for one night in the venue for like
14,000 people in the next and I was in
the village for like 12 people and
they're like well that's how it goes you
know that's yeah yeah that's how that's
probably how it will always be hmm
there's some comfort to that right well
you're like well it'll always be that
inconsistent at least you'll always work
that Mercurial lifestyle yeah I used to
bark bark anymore yeah I feel like a lot
of comics started doing I do that for a
long time well and that's yeah that
sucks someone wants to hand out flyers
but it makes you it makes it a little
sweeter when when you see those guys out
there barking you're like well you know
I used to do that and they and you know
some of them you've seen for years you
know like we should probably quit if
you're still doing like I don't working
for years yeah I've definitely seen some
faces well I'm like what you can't be
doing it wants you barking for like
seven years you gotta just not just quit
or just or just like don't quit comedy
but quit barking at lease and like how
do you get out of that life as people
get stuck I don't know I don't yeah I
don't know what it is but it's it's
tanks for sure remember
I heard the story you said about Dan st.
Germain where the guy without yeah for
10 more minutes and you'll get on stage
he's like nah PA was dancin masochist
man I mean that's like there's a
sickness to that where you're like he
was that close to getting the spot
especially early on when you'll do
anything for a spot and he was like now
I'm good and we're like do we do it open
mics you know but yeah barking is not
really a thing here though right
no man nobody I feel like that's a New
York thing for sure I can raise that if
you need to know I couldn't I mean I
have hands I could do it I was trying to
I want you to be comfortable saying I
know you've you've been through a lot
tonight
I had a frustrating morning man I you
know I gave I pulled an all-nighter last
night before my flight because well you
know I had um I had a late show and I
end up going to a party and then by the
time I got back to my hotel was like -
and then my flights at 6:00 a.m. so it's
like what am I gonna sleep for 40
minutes so I end up just I can't just
fall right asleep so I kind of just
stayed up conked out a little on the
flight made my manager checked Sean I
made sure I've early check-in at this
hotel and I they didn't they were like
though there's no rooms available I to
wait for like 90 minutes in the lobby
and of course I'm just being a dick by
the way this airports thanks this
Airport is the worst [ __ ] Airport the
world's busiest airport it's how it's
horrible
whenever there's a problem it's in
Atlanta it's at the Atlanta Airport you
notice that it's always like the power's
go down here or like totally crash yeah
yeah if it happened a couple times and
then also the walk to the uber was like
worse than the flight here to walk from
the terminal to they get new bar you
need a flight to get to the Hoover stage
you need something you know like I took
a tape there any time you land and you
have to take another shuttle you're like
that's another [ __ ] trip yeah that's
like that's naughty that's not the the
flight was a trip I know if that I can't
do that I hate the hell were you rude to
the hotel you said no I wasn't rude I
was just I was just like you're
powerless and you have nowhere for that
frustration to go so you're just kind of
like internalizing it and just bulging
with that you know so I think sure you
just and so like I was nice as I could I
was just like I just want to sleep I'm
tired and she's just like and then of
course I finally
to sleep in my room I wasn't really rude
I was just kind of pouting you know and
then I I finally get to sleep and the
[ __ ] fire alarm goes off oh my god I
wanted to punch something but there's
nothing to punch the end of just going
back to sleep dude well thanks for doing
this man I know why am i why am I doing
this are you doing this cuz I'm like Dan
st. Germain I'm a masochist we all have
that in us yeah I totally remember you
asked me last time and I was like ah
[ __ ] we shouldn't get it out that all
I'm a to ask podcast get well some
people are 3 some people are a yes and
then they just don't show up or some
people are people I know 8 the most
memorable one mr. Metzger awakened
Kurt's got other [ __ ] going on yeah wait
in his hotel lobby for about 90 minutes
wait on interview and I don't know why I
stayed but I was like I'm here cuz oh
one I didn't think it was going to be 90
minutes she's like yeah I'm on my way
down and then like 20 minutes later I
was like hey what's up he's like just
give me ten minutes and then it just
kept going it was literally like 90
minutes damn yeah so I'm a masochist as
well I will sit through it yeah you know
um Kurt Kurt Kurt [ __ ] Erica he's a
[ __ ] great comic he's a great comic
and he was working laughing skal a
weekend and like my first question him I
was like are you late to everything cuz
he was like late to some shows too and
he was like yeah my therapist says I
have like some like compartmentalizing
problem or something I was like I didn't
know even in therapy that's good for him
I had no idea oh maybe I just outed him
I don't know oh but no he doesn't seem
like he hides a lot that was the most
memorable one where I was like sitting
there just like okay so this is where I
am yeah like you said it's all that up
and down it makes you appreciate it more
I guess people say that is that true
maybe it is maybe I mean I feel like my
life was just great and then they were
like more subtle more subtle up and
downs I could deal with that too though
because everyone's like well they'll see
up and down is like yeah but that's a
rollercoaster I don't like roller
coaster I don't like like that kind of
up and downs but that's what they bets
what people say is that will you
appreciate it more I guess that's true
but then also don't you feel like I cuz
I'm traveling so much I feel just
I'm just in a constant state of
irritation because so many things go
wrong throughout the day traveling so
many little things I'm constantly like
oh come on I just like take a deep
breath and just when I'm hungover I'm
extra irritable or you pull all-nighters
yeah but also it's like it was a party I
was like I'm what am I not what am I
gonna not go to the party and get two
extra hours of sleep yeah so and then I
had food truck chili so I like heartburn
all morning Joe I made a lot of mistakes
a masochist yeah food truck chili yeah
yeah Gaffigan brought us to some party
some big movie party because he's in a
movie there and he was on the show and
he was like and I see him in New York
sometimes but we never really hang you
know cuz he's got a family and stuff so
he's always friendly but I never so I
thought I'd be fun to hang with him so
and it was only a good time what is
probably a question I always like to ask
comedians on here since we're on the
Lowe's is I always ask comedians about
like an epic bomb that they've had
whether yeah a story of getting food on
stage or just something you'll never
forget
there's just epic failure epic bombs I
mean there's one I've told a bunch is
like I did I used to work the door at
this club called Broadway comedy club
and I've been there yeah it's uh I just
was getting heckled real bad and this
guy like we went back and forth a couple
times and I had and I remember he was
like making fun of my pants and I was
like and they were like shitty pants but
it was like it's such a hack it's like
look at your pants so that was his line
I was like yeah yeah they're probably
bad but we went back and forth one time
like and he said a couple things that
like triggered me and I and I said
something that must have really
triggered him I guess I said something I
was like yeah you're [ __ ] garbage
eyes doesn't like you're a garbage
person or something
and that just set him off and he got up
any any huh and all I heard when he got
what it got up was like oh you know I
was like oh [ __ ] I knew he's gonna spit
on me oh and he tried to get to the
stage and the waitresses all liked me
though because I worked the door so they
were kind of barricaded in the stage and
he I just heard and it just right on my
shirt you know
and like terrible people have the best
Dame you know and he hit me right he hit
me right in the chest and I guess it
could have been worse right but from
that distance it was still impressive to
make contact with the spit and yeah and
then he and his girlfriend she was
humiliated I could tell but he was
waiting I'm gonna wait outside for you
he was so worked up and this guy Chris
Murphy was like I'll walk you outside on
me and he was like I mean we'd weaker
than making Chris Murphy can't see [ __ ]
he's like it looks like he's a joke
about looking like a like a he's a
redhead is a joke about looking like a
pencil and his hair is the erase or
something it's like I'm like that's
that's my muscle that's just coming with
me but he but he was brave enough to
come out with me and he made sure I got
home okay he's a nice guy he's always
been a good did how long into your
career was that I don't know that must
have been like at least eight years no
maybe ten years ago Oh ten years ago oh
yeah that was a while ago but uh yeah I
definitely didn't handle it I go that
the worst ones you look back you know I
couldn't even handle it well yeah but
you never know until after in the more
just like straight survival mode you
know with a crowd I remember I tried to
go back in the material after he spat on
me and I was like well that's not
happening you know I remember they they
were like they were shaking they were
scared for man they think they once they
pity you there's no turning around like
they pitied me you know they they I
heard a woman like got like oh yeah
there's no there's no turning that oh
yeah there was so many honors in that
set like such a lost boy and they just
yeah once they just once they're in that
mine state there's no coming back
well then you start in New York too
right yeah that's where you start in
college yeah so I mean that's pretty New
York is that's the mecca of comedy so
the fact you get to start there that
probably has to forge you're funny even
faster yeah it's it goes both ways cuz
you do but also like it's there's enough
of rooms that you can kind of I guess
you could get good quickly but I feel
like it took me a while to get
noticed which is a good thing you know
like it took me a while to become who I
wanted to be on stage and like you know
I'm still it's still working progress
you still want to improve that yeah when
you start people see you and like oh
he's they could see me like he's not
funny and they've made him their mind up
on you yeah or they could see you and be
like oh he's been here for a while he's
paid his dues so it works both ways you
know like but then there's those people
like Hannibal Burres who just come to
New York with this heat and they're
already really funny and and they're so
it so that it could work both ways you
know how long they take you into your
career before you felt like oh I'm
starting to at least get the hang of
this or start to sound like I want to
sound it took a while I was like there's
like a few jokes you're like oh that's
like what I kind of like on I am mmm you
know there's a few of those jokes that
were like what I liked and what I wanted
to sound like and it's like it
definitely takes you a while to catch up
to your tastes and comedy or like well
that's you're just doing like some weird
impression of what you want to sound
like you're not you yet you know so it
takes you a while to really from a
distance like your act may be like
you're close enough to not but it's you
have to have some sort of delusion to
stay into that young early you know
anyway so you probably have similar
delusion about your act that you're not
as bad as you think you are yeah
so that keeps you in a lot of levels but
yeah I definitely it took me a while to
be happy with it
he's like eight 10 years like I'd say
like seven or eight so I remember I was
down here and I won the festival down
here and all the other sofas and I
that's when I started to think that I
had like a couple that I'm like I'm
getting somewhere it wasn't like oh wow
my jokes are great it was like oh I have
a few that I think these are I'm on the
right track I remember even when I
wanted I thought this guy Thomas Simmons
did a better set than they know that's a
that's a weird feeling when you're like
why one but I know I you know you don't
usually feel that way because you get
everything later than you think you
deserve it
I just have a co is in comedy like so
few comics and the comics that pop off
early usually stink you know because
this is something that take it just does
take a long time to get good at this is
not there's a couple exceptions but it's
something that does take so long that
when you get it too early it's usually a
fluke it's usually because not because
you put out a great special it's because
you got something else like you want
some TV show mm-hm and that's why you
got it so when you do actually got me
out the end of my first late nights
that's like eight and a half years in or
something so was that Conan yeah that
your first and then since you've done
Colbert and Conan multiple times yeah
any others is that I've done Conan I
think four times on Colbert warrants are
those late-night shows is that more
about management to like get on to those
I don't know man I really don't know I
think like he already knew and kind of
like me in the book or I think but but
then like the first one I wasn't
thrilled with but I he was happy with it
so he was like yeah we'll definitely
have him back I I didn't like the crowd
so I thought they were the crown Conan
used to be tough another way easier but
there but oh my god there's so many late
nights it's I watch I'm just like what
the [ __ ] is happening I know what bugs
me a little bit there's so many Lena
says I'm like it's bad for comedy
because they give it to the wrong young
comics usually they give it to some
young comic who's got a little bit of
heat instead of some young comic who's
slugging away who's really [ __ ] funny
yeah they give it cus like some managers
suffocating them and they're like just
give him a shot he's ready instead of
some comic who you know guys the girls
or whatever who have seen or just
crushing it and then sometimes they get
the break but and then also it's the
mistake that everyone thinks it's gonna
be their [ __ ] you know like this will
get me yeah once I get there that's what
everything is once I get this I'll be
alright but that's how I've that's how
everything in life is right once I get
this I'll be happy it's like now you
gotta be you got to find some joy and
where you are or you're [ __ ] it seems
like those late-night sets are more just
for like other comedians to be like oh I
climbed that mountain it doesn't seem
like it really and also it's just nice
to promote stuff it's like night and I'm
clear
yeah it's also just a fun thing to do
but yeah it's and by the way the way
Colbert doesn't now it's like though
like group 5 together
yeah they don't even get the experience
of being on like one particular show
which to me is kind of a bummer because
that's my favorite part usually yeah
when I was on it it was like all other
shows well you get the whole experience
but now they're grouping like five
together and just throwing them in there
and airing it when they air it which
cutting it together it's kind of a
bummer so for the first time you
performed was that your manager that was
reaching out to the Booker or the Booker
saw you live him know my manager the
time reached out and uh you know they
like to say went back and forth a few
times and he was like here's your date
so what's amazing about your comedy and
it's all well deserved how many times
been on TV and that you're actually your
hour specials coming out this year right
yeah yeah I'm coming central is the
stuff you get away with man thanks man
is you you have figured out how to walk
the line it like it's it's the topic may
be a little off-putting like like on
your most recent conan set you're
talking about like sexual predators
right and how it's a tough you open up
by saying like it's a tough time to be a
predator right now ty break the ice yeah
that's my first the first thing I said
in the set is bad time to be a predator
yeah and you take it into like the
sports analogy like how do you I mean
how do you even evolve that joke into
being ready for TV from just something
you say in a club because I guess I'm so
fed up with the QC late-night sets where
every or every comic is trying to be
adorable
I just [ __ ] annoys me because it just
doesn't it's not genuine to me there's
something about it that's very false and
put on so and then I guess maybe that's
coupled with the fact that people don't
want to laugh at a joke just based on
the subject like a word as you said like
predator it's like that that's like a
horror joke to make funny in that you
know given the constraints of a
late-night set right so to me that's
like a challenge and it's exciting and
it's like trying to fit like almost like
a math problem like how do i crack this
code to make this work and
and the fact that people don't want to
laugh at a joke I feel like I've I've
won over someone that one of either
ordinarily liked my comedy
I don't like comedy that's like just
it's funny I was talking to a comic
about this the other night and he's a
you know very successful comic and he
said you know it used to be that like
people go to the middle of the country
and they'd persuade them to laugh at
stuff it'd be like they'd win them over
and now it seems that they're like
everyone has a brand as I look at your
water bottle and no but it's like
everyone it's a brand though and it's
like oh that's my guy and it's like I
just that's my guy but it used to be
like you kind of you won them over and
there's something about that that is
more exciting to me than just having the
not that it's ever easy to kill I don't
want to diminish people's you know
efforts in those sets but there is a
type of comedy that's a little too
easygoing for me and it doesn't it does
nothing for me it's like it almost feels
like they're kissing up to the audience
and it's like now this isn't that's I
like it to be almost like a give and
take I like it to feel more like I like
there to be awkward moments in the set
when I'm doing it especially maybe on a
late night set but when I'm doing a long
set I want I did a set in South by and
obk I got it i bombed a pretty offensive
joke it was brand-new I thought of it
before I went onstage I ran it by my
friend and he laughed and I said I'll
try and it bombed so hard and I just
[ __ ] doubled down on it I kept going
further because I was like what the [ __ ]
do I have to lose so a woman heckled me
went back it was like playful we went
back and forth be like a fun back and
forth and I maybe found something there
and it's like sometimes when you take
that risk and you bomb you find
something that's even richer you know so
maybe that's why the fact that the
really agreeable premises that are
really obvious and like I don't like
comics going up there saying I'm a nice
guy that's a lot of comics I see now I'm
a really good guy and it's like well
wasn't as easy just doing that you know
it's like so you're gonna be it just
feels like anyone who goes up who
announces they're good
is not good to me that's just in my
experience anyone who's like I'm a
really trustworthy guy it's like well
now I don't trust you
mm-hmm cuz you're like because all the
guys I always like to like they preface
it were like look I'm no sane those are
the people I trust not the people
they're like I'm a great guy I'm you
know I'm rambling over here but the
point is the point the point is I guess
I did a joke right after the parklands
shooting and it was uh about these
people didn't hit it bombed pretty hard
in st. Louis I wasn't st. Louis that
weekend and I said you know it's like
these people that believe in crisis
actors you know those people who they
think these kids aren't real kids I
think they were hired by the far-left
to be like actors and like so I said
does that mean they also believe in like
crisis actor agents like there's some
guy in the phone he's like this girl's
great she's been in Sandy Hook she's
been in part I mean you got she's gonna
be a song you got to use it so I kind of
kept up went down on it and I kept going
further and it kept bombing further and
further and I kind of liked and it mom
so hard that I kind of was like to me
it's funny though I know there's
something I feel like there's something
crackable there and like I don't know I
guess the comics I always liked in some
way what do I have to gain if it's just
something we all agree on to begin with
if it's something we all not that that
should be your whole hour because that
would probably feel weighty but if if
we're just saying like yeah this is bad
shootings are bad it's like well no
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude I mean I see these
people writing like like it's like their
virtue signaling all the time they're
jokes are like this needs to stop and
I'm like this is a [ __ ] comedy club
dude what do you just announcing like
like you're some you know like you're
some political figure you know like
shootings need to stop we all do I
really get so sick of like the uh you
know I did that joke tonight about the
baby getting eaten by the alligator at
Disney yeah and it's like this that's
basically that woman the crowd was to me
who got offended where she was like
that's not okay and I'm like well
obviously I'm not [ __ ] Pro babies
getting eaten by alligators
but if you don't like dig for a joke
there's I guess they're just like well
that's never funny I'm like well yeah do
you but like other people can find funny
[ __ ] it's it's it's weird that like when
it when something sensitive to someone
in particular they're like I'm out I'm
not laughing but but they laugh the
whole rest of the show it's just you
didn't like that one thing I was a
comedian the whole [ __ ] rest of the
show and all of a sudden now it's not
it's not comedy anymore
how do you know when you're on to a joke
because a lot of times when you tell a
joke the first time and it bombs
sometimes you abandon them you're like
oh never mind and other times is there
like if somebody gets offended you're
like okay I'm on to something there
because it's no it's not it's not it's
not like I don't want the emotional
reaction always I just want like I want
something I want some reaction it's just
I love a silly joke I love like just a
silly plain joke dude I love watching
Africana Regan or those guys yeah but
like I don't need no your on just
because you know it's it's he's gonna
get something it's gonna get something
some response so you can feel it it's
like were I did a new joke tonight that
got something it was it's not like a
perfect joke but there's something there
about like the queer eye guys about how
they're like you know I'm at the fire
house they went to and this isn't done
yet but like the idea about they were
like the firemen were all like you know
we weren't really okay with the gay guys
but then you know we got to know them
it's like oh no they just gave you a
bunch of free [ __ ] they gave you like a
hundred thousand dollars like that's not
what all gay men are like you know like
you're gonna be in for like a bad
awakening if haha if they're just like
do you like this guy Mateo and like em
he's alright didn't renovate my kitchen
you know okay but that's what they
that's what and like I felt a laugh
there shows like there's something to
play with there it's not done but
there's like a premise to play with and
uh you just know you just feel like
there's something here that feels but
then also you know there's something
that bombs so hard like well that may
never make it on stage again right it's
tough because they were so drunk early
on I couldn't really get a sense of like
silence of where to pause the way I
wanted to when you take a premise to the
stage how thought
out is it cuz you've said the paper is
the gym and like the stage is the game
so I say that yeah I in researching you
I heard you say that in an interview Wow
okay so I'm big on pin to paper I don't
know yeah I liked I don't know I guess
sometimes I talk out of my ass
I oh you just wanted to sound like smart
in that moment maybe it's the gym man
did I say that yeah I guess that makes
sense so yeah the papers a Jimmy I got
something I could have said yeah cuz no
I mean yeah I like coming up with ideas
I like I like writing [ __ ] out I also
don't like the the comics that just
completely go up there in [ __ ] you
know and just waste your time but I I
also like more the more I do it I the
less who iddin it is I think now because
I also like to just experiment a little
myself as long as I know how it ends but
I just wanna have all these jokes are
like 2/3 done like the first two parts
are funny but they don't have an ending
that's strong enough to really warrant
me to continue yeah telling them so cuz
I didn't notice even like your conan
sets your jokes they will have that arc
that it like ends on applause it like
crescendos in doing yeah you work them
out work them out till they're ready for
that you know and also it's like you
learn that those sets are different from
normal sets the crowd not all the crowds
want to evolve but some of them do so
you just know you give them just an
extra half second to see if they're
gonna clap and if not you just gotta
keep cruising but I mean they want they
usually set you up to do well the only
thing about late-night sets is I mean if
you flub a line you flub a line you know
as a special they'll let you retake it
so if I flip a line is special I get so
we do that and a late-night set that
flub could be there forever so I just
saw did you see mark Normand yeah hit
the vent at the dismount he like flubs
away flub yeah I don't want to bring
that up I knew he wouldn't be happy
about I figured us that was good it was
a killer set yeah on the dismount here
amping up and then get excited yeah I'm
sure that was all we were thinking about
I know well enough that I'm sure he's
like God I mean but it's cool to know at
every level I mean we all still like
struggle with the same things regardless
of how many times you've done something
totally yeah I mean it's those sets are
always stressful because of that but I
just talked myself into thinking the
sets are meaningless before I go on
every time like I actually do self talk
no I just I just I just in my head I'm
like this that means nothing just go
have fun and I usually do better because
I just the the looser you feel the
better you are I mean one of the sets I
was kind of drunk for I mean I and it's
actually my best set it's the one was in
the red flannel in Conan I was like
that's probably the hardest I killed it
and he said I wasn't drunk I had a
couple whiskey's and I was like not
sober
I was loose and feeling good and I'm
like I I know not to get hooked on that
but cuz because that's that's a
dangerous game to play it's like that
Jackie Chan Legend of the drunken master
she had one time you're gonna fall in
your face you know what the [ __ ] was I
thinking how meticulous is the prep for
those sets how long Conan yeah I have a
good enough relationship with the low
the first one was a little more
meticulous but word-for-word
yeah but now I'm like can I say [ __ ] and
he's like I'd rather you'd and see if
you can do it without saying [ __ ] okay I
think it's better and it and his
defensive it's usually on the money like
because they can't it's not like a cable
[ __ ] it's like it's like a regular [ __ ]
well I think they just don't let you get
the word at all okay no there's on cable
but it's late I don't know the rules
whatever but so it's better not curse no
sets but sometimes I don't know if
they're helping like I just I have no
idea what's helping and what's not
helping I think some weekends people
come out for them and then other weekend
they don't so I don't know how specific
is your performance piece because it
seems like even just to go back to the
predator joke and how you end it talking
about the Predators and the the
Nashville Predators in their name the
hockey team and then at the very end of
the joke you say I remember the last
line but you do like this hand gesture
with it is it does it come down to that
specific ow
and just gently now I think I'm just
thinking I even moved your hand in a
while okay I think that's what it is but
I look at commonly under the microscope
of like oh he raised his eyebrow there
oh he moved his hand here that's not all
super choreographed not me but that's if
I were a better comic that would
probably be May that's something that
you probably should think about but uh
no I'm just thinking like don't flub a
word don't just nail the delivery name
that I for me comedies very it's visual
but it's also like the sound of comedies
so important to me like I always thought
like like I listened to so many albums
growing up of comedy so like the way you
deliver a punch line was always
important to me that the way you as you
say a lot of the jokes and an applause
well that's a lot about how you
I think carry a voice too hmm you know
the you know how to just say the punch
line the right way you have like a lot
of comics they have a way they say a
punch line you know that's like their
punt almost like they have like their
punch line voice and it's like a cue
almost it is yeah it's very manipulative
now that we know we're talking about it
no but it's a yeah you almost like the
once they know you they know what you're
going for but I mean look it's got to be
funnier they're not gonna laugh they're
not just gonna laugh at a shitty voice
yeah so you have an actual punch line
voice at this plant that I'm aware of
really but like I think no I think
people are like I mean you know everyone
Gaffigan voice gets a little like lower
when you know it I I mean I weakened you
know certain guys have late delivery
they'll go down weather yeah or some
guys go up a African goes up uh-huh you
know so this is a music to it I guess
yeah yeah I just I just kind of wanted
to nerd out a little bit on the comedy
side especially with you because you
like didn't independent study at NYU
about it was like ancient Greek comedy
yeah I liked it a lot like what did what
did that reveal to you about comedy that
it's the same themes going back like
4000 BC you know that it's like it's the
same [ __ ] forever so it's funny it's
like they're bows when people that are
like you can't say that
they've always been those people they've
always been it's always been kind of
like a reflection of the time they were
living in like if there was a war or
something I think it reflected that
they've always been fart jokes there's
always been dick jokes there's always
been every type of joke that people find
offensive now they've been doing it
forever you know it's it's almost like
when you look at old comedy it's
probably it's like the way you look at
like a patient if you're a therapist
will be like how did people think it's
gonna be so unique but say now we're all
[ __ ] none of us are that unique we
all have there's like eight different
types of people we all fall that's like
what comedy is there's like eight
different types of comedies and they're
all they've all been going on for pretty
much like that there's a girl sometimes
that that a guy wants to be with sex
plays a big role one of the ones I
remember I think was called Lysistrata
was one were like ten the war number
women would [ __ ] the guys that's how
they ended the war they like we won't
[ __ ] you anymore and it's like kind of
interesting because it's like well it's
like the weather that shows the power of
women yeah shows that like sex has
always been a thing in comedy and it's a
pretty funny premise I mean alone if you
pitch that now to like a comedy person
they'd be like oh that's funny you know
so it shows you that like it's a funny
idea is funny
it just kind of works in a sentence you
know yeah comedy is timeless in the
sense that Chaplin still carries today
like he would still be fun today as
still funny like just a drama in the
early 1900s would probably just be
boring now how will some it depends
right I mean some of it's still hold I
mean some of its just revamp Shakespeare
right like some of the movies you see
now you're like well that's basically
just a Shakespeare so if you following
themes and things yeah but but I know
you mean like you like in tone you mean
right like sometimes like you see a
movie from the 40s and you're like you
have to kind of put it in that time cap
so cuz you're like what people don't
they don't talk like this they don't
know so but I mean I stole those of my
favorite movies usually those like 40s
and Wars
custody is like a language the way like
comedy is a language mmm you know it's
like its own thing you talk about comedy
being like math - and putting the almost
the you said cracking the code almost
yeah it's enough for me I mean I it's
that's just me being an idiot because
I'm terrible at math don't backtrack now
but well I think it's like yeah there's
almost like it's I guess the reason I
say math is because when it's solved you
know it's solved you know what I mean
like with a formula you're like well
that's the formula that's like I use you
need the exact word sometimes but
sometimes there's have a word I'm like
without that word the joke doesn't work
it's kind of interesting like I remember
I did joke what I said um you know a
teacher said to me I made up that I was
molested in a class as a joke I thought
would get a laugh Wow I thought we got a
laugh and I think it'll AB so I was in a
class where the teacher she called him
me I raised my hand as the job was in
like seventh grade she was talking about
testicular exams and I said one time my
doctor like kept his hand down there and
he played with my penis and no one
laughed and was like meant to be funny
but it wasn't funny it was just no joke
I just I just said someone molested me
so so in the joke I remember I said
something along the lines like her
saying well is that real and like this
was my app and instead I doubled down I
said you know I did instead of like bail
and I said I decide to incriminate a
pediatrician you know I said and for
whatever reason incriminate a
pediatrician so much funnier than said a
doctor [ __ ] me or somebody said a
doctor touched me it's so much funnier
because it's like I don't know it's like
the sound just like the perfect words so
it was like in that way I mean it's like
a formula where it's like oh you know
there was a gogledd them and like as you
do comedy more someone who's really good
with words is Nick DiPaolo he always
uses like the right word and a joke you
know he's good with like sounds and war
like oh that sounded really funny mm-hmm
you know like I remember to joke was
like saw a homeless guy sleeping and the
guys like sleeping like a baby he's like
I got a $800 waterbed at home meanwhile
this guy's sleeping on a Heineken
actually something like a wasted
Heineken right right a funny sound to it
just like it's like the right amount of
syllables and it's like man were sent
we're getting geeky with comedy here but
like there is a formula and like once
you figure out certain words that work
or certain rhythms to work you can't be
too predictable cuz it's got to work and
you there's no absolute code but like
once you get good at it you just get
better at those types of codes got so
you just you just work in a scale so
you'll say a joke and then be like
there's potential but there's a better
word and you almost brainstorm words
yeah it's like write down just list a
bunch of words yeah yeah cool I mean not
like there's like some cheat sheet but
it's like you have to find them yourself
find the word of course but there's like
yeah there's definitely certain words
that make me laugh always and and it's
funny cuz you can't go to someone's
blunt is funnier instead of like some
people think you need to be like as long
as I'll tell my mom a joke and she'll
say some word that's maybe a smarter
word but it just sounds too written and
I'm like we got to be talking up there
you can if this would work on a short
story version of the joke but in the
joke I need to be I can't use the word
you just said
is she thrilled did she like your brand
of comedy I don't know I make her laugh
as her son I don't know if I I don't
know if she likes
I mean she's there's things she likes
about it she didn't like my last cone
and says she told me okay yeah but it
doesn't matter you're successful I mean
your profession yeah it's not for
everybody yeah I was I mean I'll defend
the set it's not for everybody look it
was I guess the set as far as like it's
not like a mom said I did like a few
jokes about predators in Hollywood and I
did I joke about how I work condoms I
did I mean I did jokes who I'm like who
said everything she should be happy
about the condom thing that's a good
thing that was and that you were willing
to wear it yeah but uh yeah was a set
where you're like maybe just things you
don't want to think like I wouldn't want
to hear jokes about my mom
having sex yeah that's true and people
not in comedy don't look at it like oh
he got a laugh off that that's very
impressive they're like I can't believe
you said that
well yeah people close to yeah well look
I I have other people close to me who
are like I don't like that you said that
joke you know whether it be like huh you
know whoever but certain people certain
things are just for you in that person
and as comics were like well this is we
have that sense of entitlement well this
is my life I'm allowed to express myself
and forget about other people and look
I've been in other people's acts that it
doesn't throw me but I kind of just like
it's like it's part of what you kind of
what you signed up for whether or not
you signed up for it do it by by knowing
those people you signed up for it it's
just like I sent you to this college
prep school and now you're doing comedy
but I don't think I think that's like a
joke I've heard people make and I don't
think that's true like I've heard people
be like I went to Harvard and now I'm a
comedian it's like I've heard from
people who have had like good writing
jobs and like I'm like well yeah I mean
they're people go to Harvard and a
[ __ ] broke I mean wonder who gives a
[ __ ] you know I mean it's it's a school
it's and then there's some of it that's
so people that go to Harvard that are
[ __ ] not smart third book smart but
if you talk to them they're [ __ ]
morons
so and then there's people that are not
college educated that Colin Quinn is not
college educated he's one of the
smartest people that I admit you know I
mean people place too much importance on
I won't just say academic education
because there's other types of
intelligence I think but you know on
colleges and university the things like
that it's not everything and it's not
it's overrated
I mean I I'm fortunate to have gone to
the place I went to but I also like I
think there's value on other types of
education so yeah no I don't think I
don't think that's the case I think
she's like I think she thinks that I'm a
success I mean I I make a living at what
I like to do and it's and I think there
was a period where they were nervous but
now I think no me last year was a good
year I had my own I got
nominated for an Emmy on my TV show I
got an hour special recorded I I worked
the road almost every weekend as a
headliner and and I toured with some
cool people you know so it was a
productive year so I think there were
years where I felt more that about
myself where I was like I don't know and
I I still feel that way I will always
feel that like when I break down and say
oh that all sounds cool but it's not
it's such a slow bill that when you when
you say all those things at once it
sounds cool but it's just slow bill that
I I'm I'm frustrated with where I am
still because everything takes so much
[ __ ] longer than it should right
everything I've been working on a TV
show for so [ __ ] long it's just
working with these people it's
exhausting the special I taped in
December something to come out to the
fall I mean it's excruciating it's
excruciating like I want I mean they're
good problems to have they're also to me
still problems so yeah you're my hour
special isn't coming out for a while
then my TV showed it you know what I
know but you know what I'm in a
competitive bracket of headlining clubs
and you want to get that bump on the
road so people want you back you know
it's not like it's just one thing it's
exact bump I need it will help me secure
more dates it'll help me get more fans
and help me parlay this into this I mean
people were like people say things like
well you're gonna make it at some point
I'm like yeah well these other years
will be way more [ __ ] enjoyable on
the way you know I mean like I was
talking to Roy Wood jr. about it the
other day the comic and he was saying
he's uh was telling me I was talking
about you know hey it's success later
you know it's taken you a while you know
and he's such a real comic I think it's
a great comic amazing but he he's like
yeah man I really haven't been able to
like when you when you have success
later you don't really get to enjoy
success that long it's just how he put
it I was like that's a good way to put
it I mean it's like he's right I mean
you yeah it's a shorter part of your
life but then there's people that blow
up super early as we talked about
earlier in this podcast they have all
this hype early on and they just fizzle
right the [ __ ]
the comics comics a Gascon and Louie
have said to me that like the way you
want to succeed in this is to have that
slow build but also that's what both of
them have so someone you're like are you
just saying what you did right all right
but I think I mean I think they are
right but there was a part of me that's
like [ __ ] it took Louis so long you know
it's a Gavigan so long but here they are
so we have milestones along the way so
it's yeah cool to catch you at this
moment in your career to where you are
you have stuff coming up in the future
and you've just had some great success
so and the fact dude you're willing to
sit down and do this after pulling an
all-nighter and then having to get up
early tomorrow to travel out again after
doing this show at the punchline in
front of drunk people they were [ __ ]
drunk dude I deserve better I really
that's the thing I say I it's funny what
she grown to one of things I said no was
like no no you're mistaken I have a high
selfish
you like that's that's the funny thing
is when they like they do the all and
I'm like no I think I'm I deserve a
smarter crowd I think you're a [ __ ]
idiot like that's that's the whole thing
that woman was such a drunk she came
into my green room and one [ __ ] go
away I was like what do you think so you
I have to perform for someone who's who
doesn't know the boundaries that you
don't that you shouldn't go into
someone's private space with her
preparing for a show she thinks it's
okay there and that's that's the level
of awareness I'm performing for after
2,700 people the night before but that's
just how it goes right that's how it
always is yeah you know I mean that's
what this career is always gonna be it's
like and look you got to be grateful I
didn't gotta be grateful for the good
and then just hope that there's not too
much bad I mean this is I could see this
being a good club but just tonight was
they were they were not my favorite type
of crab there were some people that were
really good in there yeah this is I mean
energy at least you know great club but
this is a weird night and people came to
get drunk I guess it sounds like that's
tough cuz I like getting drunk too but
the more I realize I'm like I I'm a
better drunk that I have give myself
credit for I'm really not that bad a
drunk like who are these [ __ ] 60 plus
year olds who are still drinking like
this yeah what is it what is the inside
of their body like I don't know but
they're still alive so they're doing
something right I guess I just grilled
us on the way out till you see that yeah
but we'll go ahead and wrap it up I
appreciate you taking time to do this
man yeah and uh before we get out of
here is there anything else you want the
world to know I don't know what does
this come out I may release this one
this week actually I'm pretty jazzed
about it yeah hope I probably made no
sense for a few these I'm pretty
sleep-deprived right now I'm sure I
rambled a little too much on this one
you did great I don't know I got a
podcast called keeping Joe with Phil
Hanley and Joe Mackey the last one that
came out with John laster's one of my
favorite episodes it's really good
talked a lot about his addiction and he
was really opening great and then the
one that comes out next week with Allan
Havey is another one of my favorites
Allan Havey is you know been around
forever yeah you know had his own show
on MTV like back in the day I hope
Comedy Central I think too was a big
character on Mad Men which was one of my
all-time favorite shows been on Seinfeld
he's like he's the man I love I love
Allan Havey so he's so good on the show
so those are two my favorite episode so
she'll probably like those and yeah and
the hour special probably the fall but
who the [ __ ] knows maybe 2,500 20:27 run
my hour special
hopefully the fall you almost like don't
believe anything until after it happens
right I feel like they could call me be
like it's coming out tomorrow I'm like
wait a second I need like I need a PR
person or something but like no it's
it's gonna come out and like I think the
fall and you know I'm gonna do
everything I can to make sure people see
it I know it's I know it's like tough to
promote cable these days but like I
think I think we'll hopefully get enough
of it online that people like I know
some people blew up by getting just
enough clips online I think like my plan
is to get enough YouTube clips of their
from the special that it's like almost
like late-night sets that people can
share you know so yeah that's my plan I
think they seemed receptive so I'll say
and I think I'm really proud of the
special I think it's the best thing I've
ever done so and even the opening is
really funny it's a cool sketch opening
oh you did a sketch opening it's it's
all show I'll show you the after this
that's awesome well Sam Morelle thanks
for being on hot breath thanks for
having me when talking I'll show to you
if I have it's pretty funny
[Music]